we're all gonna die someday and if
you're gonna pick some place to die then
why not long if you want to die having
lived an adventurous life then you have
to do adventurous things we all get to
choose our life stories and it's the
choices that define us not our gifts
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up believe nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee and
sip on today's message be an adventurer
over to you Elon Musk also if you want
to know what Elon Musk and other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series
where every day for the next 254 days I
will send you a morning video for free
to help you build your confidence the
link to join is in the description below
there are times when something is
important enough you believe it enough
that you do it in spite of fear once you
said do you want to die Mars why I don't
be clear I don't want to die on it but
it's like if I mean we're all gonna die
someday and if you're gonna pick some
place to die then why not Mars
you know if we're born on earth why not
die on Mars seems like maybe quite
exciting but I think given the choice of
dying on earth or dying on Mars I'd say
yeah sure I'll do and Mars but it's not
some kind of Mars death wish and and if
I do die on Mars I just don't want it to
be on impact you are afraid to make big
bold statements about what your dreams
are in the world that you want to build
because you are afraid of people's
judgments because people tell you that
you're crazy because people tell you
that you can't do it because people tell
you that it'll never happen and because
you are afraid of other people's
judgments that will keep you thinking
small that will keep you playing small
that will keep you
exactly where you are but you don't want
to because you want to be playing a
bigger game your life doesn't have to
suck if you have a big dream for
yourself it's never been easier to
accomplish it it's about shifting your
mindset if you want to die having lived
an adventurous life then you have to do
adventurous things so how do you stay
adventurous in the face of ridicule I'm
gonna give you three tips to help you
number one is find your one word your
one word is your single most important
core value that you stand for and this
is what happens when you understand what
your one word is it's like you are
standing on a rock you are standing on a
rock where everybody else is standing on
quicksand when you know who you actually
are what your single most important core
value is then people can't push you from
that rock then people's judgement of you
and that one word of what you stand for
won't mean anything to you you won't
play small because of what other people
think and so when I found believe it not
only sets the course it only charts the
path of here's what I don't want to do
here's what I want to build but for
people who don't believe in believe when
there's lots of people not not anymore
really in this community because we've
cultivated and built it up but there's
people who hate belief and that's
awesome and I don't care about their
judgement because I'm so secure knowing
that this at the core is Who I am
and if you don't agree with it amazing
doesn't mean you're a bad person it just
means that we are not meant to follow
the same path together when you don't
know what you stand for when you don't
know what your core value is when you
don't know what your one word is then
you're constantly seeking other people's
approval because you're not sure in
yourself whoever is more confident wins
and because you lack confidence in
yourself you're gonna be pulled to what
other people's judgments are and there's
no way that you can live an adventurous
life on your terms if you don't even
know what your terms are so number one
most important figure out what your
single most important one word core
value is number two is design your
habits and environment if you know what
your one word is and you start to build
an environment and habits around it if
you know your one word is adventure you
want to be an adventurer amazing what
are your habits and your environment to
help you remind yourself to be an
adventurer every day
what is
physical environment looks like what
does the office look like this means
something to me this helps me believe it
may not mean anything to you but it
means something to me every day I walk
into this office design your physical
space your bedroom your office your home
office wherever you are spending time
the background on your cell phone your
computer design your environment as a
consistent reminder to be adventurous or
whatever your one word is also your
morning routine your habits what do you
spend your time on the first 15 minutes
of every single day you should chart
your start you should stop waking up
like an accident you should stop waking
up and responding to other people's
emergencies and do the thing that helps
you feel like an adventurer or whatever
your one word is do that thing because
you have felt it you have felt that
boldness that courageous says at some
point in your life you have felt like an
adventurer you felt believe you felt
your one word consistently over some
period of time what is the thing that
you need to do to start your day so that
you are feeling that because if you woke
up if your one word is adventure and you
woke up every single day and did the
thing that made you feel like an
adventurer
holy cow your life would be totally
different one year from today compared
to where you are right now design your
habits in your environment and number
three is be the tree I use this analogy
of a tree of what does a tree do the
breezin poison carbon dioxide is so the
tree doesn't breathe in inhales poison
carbon dioxide each it um eats it grows
from it grows strong into this mighty
tree and then spits out oxygen spits out
positivity and I think when you
understand what your one word is when
you know what you stand for when you
understand your core values if you know
you want to be an adventurer then when
people judge you for it
this is part of your role as an
entrepreneur you're gonna take their
judgement you're gonna eat it you're
gonna grow stronger from it and then
you're gonna spit out positivity for
everybody else who wants me an
adventurer too but it's too afraid
you'll be able to handle other people's
judgments and go after your dreams is
not only helping you go accomplish your
dreams it's helping everybody who
watches you everybody who is afraid
everybody who doesn't want to take
action because they're afraid of
judgement
- and seeing you do it seeing you eat it
grow from it get stronger build
something bigger will be an inspiration
for other people to take action on their
dreams - entrepreneurs you gotta be a
tree now I've got a really special bonus
scoop that I think you're gonna enjoy
but before that question of the day I
want to know what is your big crazy
dream that you are afraid to tell people
about I want you to get used to sharing
it I want you to start to get used to
feeling that judgment eating it and
growing from it let me know what is your
crazy dream put it down in the comments
below
you can choose we all get to choose our
life stories and it's the choices that
define us not our gifts everybody in
this room has many gifts I have many
gifts you can never be proud of your
gifts because their gifts they were
given to you you might be you know tall
or you might be really good at math or
you might be extremely beautiful or
handsome or you know there are there
many gifts and you can only be proudly
of your choices because those are the
things that you are that you're that you
are acting on and one of the most
important choices that each of us has
and you know this just as well as I do
is you can choose a life of ease and
comfort or you can choose a life of
service and adventure and when you're 80
which one of those things you think
you're gonna be more proud of you're
gonna be more proud of having chosen a
life of service or adventure if you
think about life you can be nihilistic
about life like what's the purpose at
the end of the day you can dissect
anything and go what's the purpose some
people go you know I want to make a
billion dollars and you can say to them
what's the purpose we all die we all end
up in the same small grave at the end of
the day and you can say I want to become
super intelligent or I want to have them
get married and have kids at the end of
the day all flesh is grass and you
disappear just like the grass eventually
so for me the best guess I had it maybe
other people have spiritual things and
all that and the best guess I've ever
come up with is like if every day you
wake up and you go I don't have it all
figured out let's jump into something
crazy and see what happened that's how I
got started on social media I started
really dabbling with it in 2012-2013
then in 2014 if someone was like you
should do YouTube it's gonna be big so I
was like let's try a new adventure and I
just started shooting my first videos in
January 25th 2016 2015 sorry I put out
this video and it it's ended up to me
literally different versions have like
six hundred million views it's gotten a
lot of views and
my garage here in my garage and some
other similar garage themed ones
everybody should try to be rich and
famous at least once and should get it
just to realize it's not as good as you
think but the adventure part school and
also when I say adventure I also mean
gaining insight into life the biggest
thing I've learned if I could be 18
again I wish somebody had told me
basically nobody knows what they're
doing even the adults you think you know
everybody's lost in the world is the
blind leading the blind so the ultimate
adventure to me is not just like bungee
jumping or something like that are going
to the Amish it's trying to get insight
and see life as a puzzle and your goal
in life is to seek the adventures that
piece the puzzle together so that at the
end of your life you like kind of get
get it you kind of get it I feel like
most people don't get what life is raise
your standard Apple at the core its core
values not one drop of most self-worth
depends on job it's supposed to mean and
if you want more Elon Musk's check out
the how to be the next Elon Musk video
that I made the link is right there next
to me I think you'll enjoy it continue
to believe and I'll see you there
a challenge for entrepreneurs is to say
well what's the difference between
really believing in new ideals versus
pursuing some unrealistic dream